blâme contre son collectif
antiracisme des coloniales, un
débat tenu à huis clos mais qui
risque de laisser des traces.
Radio-Canada a obtenu des
extraits de ce débat.
- Manon Massé passe le flambeau.
MANON MASSÉ, co-porte-parole,
Québec solidaire
- J'ai des fourmis dans
les jambes, mais en ce moment,
je suis dans un rôle
qui m'use, un rôle
qui parfois m'éteint.
- Elle reste co-porte-parole,
elle demeure députée, mais
en septembre, c'est Gabriel
Nadeau-Dubois qui prendra sa
place comme chef parlementaire.
GABRIEL NADEAU-DUBOIS, co-porte-
parole, Québec solidaire
- Chers solidaires,
lors de notre prochain congrès,
je vais non seulement solliciter
un nouveau mandat à titre
de co-porte-parole, mais je vais
aussi vous demander votre
confiance comme candidat
de notre parti au poste
de premier ministre du Québec.
- Les rôles changent,
mais ils feront toujours équipe
pour rallier les troupes.
Le parti sort à peine d'un
épisode de querelle interne.
- C'est adopté à la majorité.
- La motion de blâme
du collectif antiraciste
décolonial a été adoptée
dans une proportion de 81 %,
mais le débat laisse un goût
amer à certains militants.
ANDRÉ FRAPPIER,
délégué Laval-des-Rapides
- Je suis déçu et fâché
de voir la façon dont ce...
En fait, ce n'est pas un débat,
c'est un procès qu'on fait.
- Plusieurs délégués
ont exprimé leur malaise.
RABAH MOULLAH,
comité de coordination national
- C'est la démarche qui consiste
à sanctionner publiquement,
à la vue de nos adversaires,
un collectif interne qui
me dérange. Cette façon de faire
peut créer des blessures
difficiles à panser.
ANGÉLIQUE SOLEIL LAVOIE,
Commission nationale des femmes
- La commision nationale
des femmes n'arrivait pas
à se positionner sur le sujet.
- Je vais vous parler aussi
de mes collègues députés.
- La députée Ruba Ghazal,
de son côté, a parlé
d'un inconfort persistant
des élus face au collectif.
RUBA GHAZAL, députée de Mercier
- Ça fait très longtemps.
Attaran, ça, c'est la goutte
qui a fait déborder le vase.
Ils se sentent heurtés par
les façons de faire du CAD.
- Le temps initialement prévu
pour la délibérante est écoulé.
- Le débat, qui devait
initalement être clos
en 30 minutes, a été prolongé.
- On va donner une prologation
de 20 minutes, et je suis
rendue au tour de parole
d'Émilie Poirier.
ÉMILIE POIRIER,
déléguée de Beauharnois
- En fait, pour moi, une motion
de blâme, c'est juste
de nommer mon malaise
de camarade à camarade.
- Tous n'ont pas la tête
à la camaraderie.
AUDREY PAQUET,
déléguée Rivière-du-Loup
- Moi, j'ai le goût de brûler
ma carte de membre juste
parce qu'on en traite.
- L'objectif du conseil national
était de commencer à préparer
les troupes pour les prochaines
élections. Malgré le tumulte,
les délégués se sont entendu
pour mettre l'environnement
au coeur de la campagne.
On verra si les membres
du collectif antiraciste
décolonial rentreront
dans les rangs ou quitteront
le parti d'ici là.
Ici Valérie Gamache,
Radio-Canada, Q